the difference between smart people know  what they want  and why people know what they don't want  so i have a lot of smart people it's  difficult to deal with smart people  very difficult it's easy to deal with  stupid people you know they follow they  go to toilet they go to the restaurant  together  but smart people is all different but  what we need a company  is not it's not a farm my company is a  zoo  we have all kinds of animals  people talk people never talk people  work hard people never  work i mean these are this is this is  amazing  ecosystem of the company that made the  company very very powerful and colorful  i feel happy that and a leader is not  the proof you are smarter than the  others  a leader job is to making sure  everybody giving their smart ideas out